- Ich bin die Astrid Kuth.
Ich bin hier die Küchenchefin und die
Inhaberin im Restaurant Strandhaus.
- Mein Name ist Günter Grote-Vallée
und ich arbeite als Restaurantleiter
hier im Restaurant Strandhaus.
- Der Gast steht hier immer im
Mittelpunkt. Und das ist halt wichtig,
dass die Leute zum Gast
einfach offen und freundlich sind.
- Es kommt natürlich auch sehr,
sehr viel Fachwissen noch dazu.
- Ein ganz normaler Arbeitstag
im Restaurant beginnt:
Restaurantfachmann Günter
kümmert sich um den Gästeraum.
In der Küche haben die Vorbereitungen
für das Essen angefangen:
Das Gemüse wird geputzt
und geschnitten.
Die Kartoffeln werden geschält.
Es wird gekocht und gebraten.
Beim Personalessen bespricht das Team,
was für diesen Tag wichtig ist.
Günter und Astrid sprechen
über weitere Details.
Die ersten Gäste kommen
und werden von Günter begrüßt.
Zuerst gibt es etwas zu trinken,
während in der Küche
schon das Essen zubereitet wird.
Günter serviert das Essen
und wünscht den Gästen guten Appetit.
Mehr über den Beruf des Restaurantfachmanns
erfahrt ihr im nächsten Teil.
- Wir müssen noch mal gerade überlegen,
wir hatten ja heute die Reservierung
für die Überraschungsmenüs,
was wir den Gästen machen.
Lukas, was hast du als Vorspeise?
- Als Vorspeise habe ich
Pulpo und Zucchinisalat.
- Okay. Und als Hauptgang,
was machen wir da?
- Was machst du für ein Fleisch?
- Ich hab Maishähnchenbrust.
- Kartoffelstrudel und Spitzkohl hab ich.
- Und dann mach ich noch
ein paar Pfifferlinge dazu.
- Ja!
- Nachtisch haben wir auch schon?
- Ah, ja, lass mal überlegen …
Ich hab Erdbeerparfait und Vanilleeis.
- Okay, ja. Klingt doch nach ’nem ...
Das wird ihnen schmecken.
Ich hoffe, die hatten ...
Sonderwünsche waren da nicht?
- Nee, bisher nicht.
Aber wenn noch irgendwas kommt –
ich frag ja noch mal,
dann sag ich Bescheid.
- Alles klar, machen wir so.
Gut!
- Heute Abend haben wir den Zehnertisch,
den haben wir als Überraschungsmenü.
Dann haben wir, glaub ich,
einen Geburtstag für vier Personen.
Die bestellen aber à la carte
und dann machen wir Glosche.
- Alles klar.
- Also Feuerwerk so ein bisschen.
- Ja, wunderbar. Machen wir so,
kein Thema.
- Und an Tisch acht
hab ich einmal Allergie gegen Salbei.
- Ja.
- …, ob da alles im Menü okay ist.
- Okay, und wenn da sonstige
Sonderwünsche kommen,
müsstest du mir dann
noch Bescheid sagen.
- Mach ich.
- Ja? Alles klar!
- Restaurant Strandhaus,
Grote-Vallée, schönen guten Tag!
Hallo, Herr Butzbach!
Morgen? Für wie viele Personen?
Zwei Personen, das klappt.
Um welche Uhrzeit möchten
Sie kommen morgen?
19 Uhr, okay.
So, der Name war Butzbach mit tz?
Ja, wie ist der Vorname?
Bruno.
Dann bräuchte ich noch
eine Telefonnummer, Herr Butzbach.
0176, ja, 48, alles klar.
Hab ich dann drin:
morgen Abend 19 Uhr für zwei Personen.
Alles klar, bis morgen. Tschüss.
- Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
- Hatten Sie einen Tisch bestellt?
- Ja, für zwei Personen.
- Auf welchen Namen?
- Butzbach.
- Alles klar. Möchten Sie drinnen
oder lieber draußen sitzen?
- Gerne draußen.
- Ja, ist dann einmal hier vorne.
Kommen Sie bitte mit.
- Danke.
- Hallo, guten Abend.
- Guten Abend.
- Schon mal die Karten.
- Danke schön.
- Bitte sehr.
Schon was zu trinken für Sie?
Ein Gläschen Wein zum Essen vielleicht?
- Ich hätte gerne einen Weißwein, ja.
- Möchten Sie einen Riesling,
der ist eher spritzig,
oder lieber einen Weißburgunder,
der ist ein bisschen milder, fruchtig?
- Dann nehme ich den Weißburgunder.
- Den Weißburgunder, gerne.
Und für Sie auch ein Glas Wein?
Rosé vielleicht zum Hauptgang?
- Nee, ich nehm lieber ein Bier.
- Ein Pils oder ein Kölsch?
- Ich hätt gern ein Kölsch.
- Ja? Gerne. Alles klar.
Einmal das Kölsch, bitte schön.
Da habe ich für Sie den Weißburgunder.
Sie können gerne mal
ein Schlückchen probieren.
- Danke.
- Bitte schön.
- Haben Sie schon entschieden,
was Sie essen möchten?
- Ja.
- Ja? Was dürfen wir Ihnen denn bringen?
- Für mich gerne die Burrata.
- Gerne.
- Die wird ohne Nüsse zubereitet, oder?
- Ja, also wir können …
… müssen das Dressing ändern,
weil Nussöl drin ist, aber das ist
kein Problem, das kriegen wir hin.
- Gerne!
- Gerne, für Sie?
- Für mich bitte die
Gurken-Joghurt-Millefeuille.
- Ja, gerne.
Bei Ihnen auch irgendwas,
worauf wir achten müssen?
Irgendwas, was Sie nicht vertragen?
- Nee.
- Nee, alles gut? Okay.
- Ich ess alles.
- Und im Hauptgang,
was darf ich Ihnen da mitbringen?
- Für mich gerne das Saint-Pierre-Filet.
- Den Saint-Pierre, gerne.
- Und ich hätt als Hauptgang
gerne den Kalbsrücken
mit Pfifferlingen und den Kalbsrücken
gerne rosa gebraten.
- Machen wir, gerne. Alles klar.
Einmal den Saint-Pierre für Sie.
- Danke sehr.
- Bitte schön.
Und der Kalbsrücken.
- Danke.
- Bitte schön.
Guten Appetit wünsche ich!
- Danke.
- Wie hat es Ihnen denn geschmeckt?
War alles in Ordnung?
- Ja, sehr gut, danke.
- Mir auch.
- Danke sehr.
Möchten Sie noch mal einen Blick
in die Dessertkarte werfen
oder ist so weit alles in Ordnung?
- Nee, war alles gut.
Wir hätten gern die Rechnung bitte.
- Alles klar, bring ich Ihnen gerne.
- Danke.
- Ich zahle mit Karte bitte.
- Gerne, hab ich schon dabei.
Dann einmal die Geheimzahl
und mit Okay bestätigen bitte.
Danke schön.
Und die für Sie zurück.
Brauchen Sie einen Bewirtungsbeleg?
- Ja, ich nehm den Beleg mit.
- Ja, mach ich Ihnen fertig,
kleinen Augenblick!
- Der Gast steht hier immer
im Mittelpunkt. Und das ist halt wichtig,
dass die Leute zu dem Gast einfach
offen und freundlich sind.
- Es kommt natürlich auch sehr,
sehr viel Fachwissen noch dazu:
Über das Essen muss man
Bescheid wissen, das heißt,
wenn die Teller am Pass stehen in der
Küche, muss man direkt sehen, was es ist.
Also man muss
verschiedene Fleischsorten kennen,
verschiedene Gemüsesorten kennen,
man muss sich mit Wein auskennen,
man muss nachher wissen,
welcher Wein passt zu welchem Essen,
weil das gehört auch dazu,
dass man die Gäste berät.
Also es kommt auch noch sehr,
sehr viel an Fachkenntnis [hinzu],
gerade im Bereich Essen und Trinken.
- Aber auch wichtig ist
die Kommunikation im Team.
So was muss jemand, der hier arbeitet,
natürlich auch können.
- Wenn man noch gar keine Erfahrung hat,
kann man gucken, ob irgendwo
ein Aushilfsjob meinetwegen angeboten wird,
wo man dann angelernt wird.
Da wird man angelernt für das,
was in dem Restaurant gebraucht wird.
Und wenn man sich dann dazu
entscheidet, eine Ausbildung zu machen,
ja dann geht’s halt los.
Dann ist noch die Berufsschule mit dabei,
um die ganzen
theoretischen Sachen zu lernen,
und die Praxis lernt man dann im Betrieb.
- Wichtig ist halt, dass man den Betrieb
findet, der zu einem passt,
und dass man dann
auch in den Betrieb passt
und zu den Kollegen und ins Team.
- Der einzige Nachteil ist die Arbeitszeit,
dass man halt viel am Wochenende arbeiten
muss und auch viel abends arbeiten muss.
Also wenn Geburtstagsfeiern sind,
dass man auch mal keine Zeit hat,
um da hinzugehen.
Die Vorteile sind,
dass wirklich jeder Tag anders ist,
dass man sehr viel
Abwechslung hat in dem Beruf.
Also man macht zwar
jeden Tag das Gleiche,
aber dadurch, dass jeden Tag
andere Gäste da sind –
manchmal hat man einen Zehnertisch,
manchmal hat man einen Geburtstag,
manchmal eine Hochzeit, also
jeder Tag läuft wirklich komplett anders,
und das macht halt super Spaß.
Die Gäste sind normalerweise echt nett.
Und was auch richtig viel Spaß macht, ist,
wenn die Gäste mit
schlechter Laune kommen
und mit guter Laune wieder gehen.